BEFORE I COME TO A CONCLUSION.
>> Laura: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU HEARD ME TALK ON THE "ANGLE"
ABOUT HOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE
CLINGING TO THIS VICTIM HOOD
NARRATIVE.
HOW DID THAT IMPACT THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND
THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE?
JOINING ME NOW CAN BRUCE, THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL DIVERSITY COALITION FOR
CRUMP AND HENRY DAVIS FOUNDER OF
THE CONSERVATIVE URBAN PROJECT
IN D.C. FOR THE CELEBRATION OF
BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
BRUCE, LET'S START WITH YOU.
THIS IS WILD.
WE HAVE JUSSIE SMOLLETT MAKES
$125,000 AND THE POLICE MAKE
$48,000.
BRUCE, THAT'S NOT ENOUGH MONEY.
GET GUYS TO ATTACK.
>> YOU THIS PLAYS INTO THE SAME
OLD THING.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS IN THE
GREENROOM.
HOW THE LEFT ALWAYS TRIES TO
PORTRAY BLACK FOLKS LIKE US TO
INTIMIDATE US.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST VOTER
SUPPRESSION IN THE LAND OF THE
LEFT.
THIS IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
DON'T GO OVER THERE.
THEY ARE BAD PEOPLE.
THE DISHEARTENING PART IS WE HAD
ISSUES IN THE PAST.
WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY.
THE PRESIDENT TONIGHT, OH MY
GOD, HE WAS SO ON FIRE!
PRESIDENT TRUMP, YOU WERE
KILLING IT TONIGHT.
HE WAS SO EXCITED.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN HISTORY MONTH.
HE WAS CELEBRATED.
PACKED JAM ROOM.
SCREAMING AND LOUD.
HE WAS SO HAPPY ABOUT THE LOWEST
BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT AND ALL OF
THESE GREAT INITIATIVES AND HERE
WE GO.
JUSSIE SMOLLETT.
>> Laura: ISN'T THAT WHY THEY
ARE SELLING THIS YOU ARE
OPPRESSED, YOU ARE A VICTIM.
WATCH OUT FOR THE GUYS WITH THE
RED HAT.
THEY ARE COMING FOR YOU.
IT'S THE WORST KIND OF SCARE
TACTIC.
THEY ARE DOING IT BECAUSE THINGS
ARE GETTING BETTER.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY SO
MANY PEOPLE HATE BLACK PEOPLE OR
PEOPLE THAT LOOK LIKE ME, HATE
THIS PRESIDENT.
THIS MAN HAS DONE MORE THAN ANY
OTHER PRESIDENT HAS DONE FOR
PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE ME AND HIM
THAN EVER.
I WEAR THE MAGA HAT VERY FAR I
GO AND WALK AROUND SAINT WITH GO
TRUMP OR CRY T-SHIRT ON.
JUSSIE SMOLLETT NEEDS TO SIT
DOWN SOMEWHERE IN HIS CELL.
GET SOME PEOPLE PUTTING MONEY ON
HIS BOOK.
[LAUGHING].
>> Laura: WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
I HAVE TO SHARE SOMETHING WITH
YOU.
YOU ARE BIG ELIZABETH WARREN
FANS.
SHE CHANGED THE SUBJECT AWAY
FROM JUSSIE SMOLLETT OF HOW THE
DEMOCRATS WILL HELP THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN COMMUNITY
SOMETHING TRUMP APPARENTLY WON'T
DO.
LET'S WATCH.
>> IT'S A FULL SCREEN.
SHE SAID WE MUST CONVERT THE
DARK HISTORY OF SLAVERY THAT HAS
HAD MANY CONSEQUENCES.
UNDERMINING THE ABILITY OF BLACK
FAMILIES TO BUILD WEALTH:
SHE IS TALKING ABOUT
DESPERATION.
WRITE A CHECK.
>> SHE IS TALKING ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS.
THAT'S WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
DOING.
THAT'S WHY WE AS PEOPLE THAT
LOOK LIKE ME AND HIM ARE IN THE
POSITION THAT WE ARE IN IS
BECAUSE OF THE DEMOCRATS.
I AM TRYING TO TELL YOU RIGHT
NOW, LAURA, DONALD TRUMP IS THE
MOST PRO-AND THIS IS A QUOTE
FROM MY FRIEND PASTOR DARRYL
SCOTT, AND I WILL BE WORKING
WITH HIM AND KAREEM.
>> Laura: YOU GOT THAT OUT FAST.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS THE MOST
PRO-BLACK PRESIDENT WE HAVE EVER
SEEN IN OUR LIFETIME.
>> Laura: THEY ARE PETRIFIED OF
DONALD TRUMP.
TAKING EVEN 5% OF THE BLACK VOTE
AWAY.
KANYE WEST SAID GET OFF THE
PLANTATION.
>> HERE WE GO AGAIN.
VOTER SUPPRESSION.
THROW THE BOOGEYMAN IN THE ROOM
AND INTIMIDATE US.
AT THE END OF THE DAY PRESIDENT
TRUMP WILL BE THE CHAMPION FOR
BLACK AMERICA.
I AM A 27 YEAR BUSINESS OWNER IN
ATLANTA.
THERE ARE MANY OF US ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THAT WANT THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
THIS PRESIDENT IS THE BEST
PRESIDENT IN HISTORY!
IN HISTORY!
>> Laura: VICTIMWOOD.
WHAT DO YOU TELL THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN KID WATCHING?
MAYBE A 20-YEAR-OLD WATCHING.
WHEN THEY SAY YOU ARE A VICTIM
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> THAT'S A LIE.
>> I DITTO THAT.
>> THE NUMBERS DON'T LIE.
DON'T GET CAUGHT UP ON THE
EMOTIONS.
FOR BLACK AMERICANS.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE S-HOLE
COUNTRY COMMENTS?
>> THAT'S EMOTION.
THAT DOESN'T PAY BILLS.
IT JUST KEEPS THIS JUNK GOING.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP AIN'T SCARED.
HE GOT THAT --
>> Laura: I NEED ONE OF THOSE
SHIRTS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Laura: I AM HANGING OUT WITH